N'empêche, ils y a des milliers
d'Hagan aujourd'hui qui veulent
quitter le pays. Les grandes
capitales cherchent à évacuer
les ressortissants.
Les Américains n'auraient pas
pu imaginer pire scénario.
Les forces alliées n'ont pas
même encore terminé leur retrait
d'Afghanistan que les Talibans
marchent déjà sur Kaboul.
Dans une adresse à la nation,
le président afghan a insisté
sur l'importance de mieux
mobiliser les troupes afghanes,
avant de lui-même s'enfuir
quelques heures plus tard
pour, a-t-il dit,
éviter un bain de sang.
La prise du pouvoir par
les Talibans ne fait maintenant
plus de doute, mais
le secrétaire d'État américain
maintient toujours que
les États-Unis ont pris la bonne
décision en se retirant.
"Rester en Afghanistan
aurait exposé nos troupes
au feu des Talibans, dit-il.
Il aurait fallu de nouveau
engager le combat."
N'empêche, à Washington,
on s'étonne de voir
les quelque 300 000 membres
des forces afghanes, entraînées
et équipées à grands frais
par les Américains, offrir
si peu de résistance.
MILOUD CHENNOUFI, Collège des
forces canadiennes de Toronto
- Cet échec, encore une fois,
était prévisibile. Pourquoi?
Parce que c'est une armée qui
est construite par une puissance
occupante, ou perçue comme
telle, par ceux-là même sur
lesquels on a voulu compter
pour construire cette armée-là.
Donc, leur débâcle face
aux Talibans exprime beaucoup
plus leur faiblesse
que la puissance des Talibans.
- L'administration Biden essuie
pourtant les attaques nourries
de ses adversaires.
Ce républicain compare
l'évacuation de l'ambassade
américaine à la chute de Saïgon,
au Vietnam, en 1975.
Cet autre parle d'un échec
épique. Le président, dit-il,
aura du sang sur les mains.
La Maison-Blanche a contre-
attaqué dans une déclaration
écrite. Le président Biden
rappelle que la décision
de retirer les troupes a été
prise par l'administration
Trump. Rester en Afghanistan
encore plusieurs années
ne servirait pas l'intérêt
national, dit-il, ajoutant
que les vies de milliers
de vies de jeunes Américains
auraient été mises à risque.
Ici Hugo Lavallée,
Radio-Canada, W